ふぅ…。
新しいベイブレードが出る度にやる気が出ます!
はじめしゃちょーです。
遂にアタッシュケースに入れるようになったよ。
俺も!末期DA☆
というわけでまだ何やかんやでベイブレードやってるんですけれども
ベイブレード今滅茶苦茶色んなのが出たんですよ。
そろ↑そろ↓!
そろそろ最強のベイブレード作ってもいいんじゃねーかと思いました。
なんかドリルで作ったり、
僕も色々強いベイブレードを作って試行錯誤したんですけども
私は遂に辿り着きましたよ。
最強のベイブレードとは何かを!!
そのベイブレード!とは!
ベイブレードが唯一地面に接触する部分、ドライバーです。
まぁ見てのとおり色々ある訳なんですけども、
こういうところが地面にぶつかるわけなんで、
此処の形によってね、どういう動きをするかが決まります。
例えばこういう「メタルボール」だったら凄い回転しやすかったり、
こういう「ゴムグリップ」だったら持久力はないんですけども、凄い攻撃的な動きをしたり、
これとかもそうですね。攻撃的な動きをしそうです。
結局ドライバーなんじゃねーかなと思いまして。
どんなに重いものをつけたり、攻撃的なこの上のパーツをつけたりしても、
結局ね、止まったら負けなんですよ。ベイブレードは。
止まったら負けなんで結局持久力があるベイブレードが一番強いんじゃないか説が僕の中にはあるので今日はなんと!
あぁ～じゃっ
こちら!
あーローソン。
画鋲でございます。
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ…
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ…(゜∀゜)
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ!!!(。∀゜)
なんでこんな単純なことに気付かなかったんだろう。
もうシンプルに画鋲をこのドライバーに付ければ、
あんだけ尖ってたらもう持久力最強なんですよ。
純粋に画鋲をつければ滅茶苦茶安定して持久力もあって、
最強のベイブレードになるんじゃないかと思ったので今回は画鋲をつけて!ベイブレードをやってみようと!思います!
うあぁ…!うぅぅ～…。なんか…ヤバい。病院の注射を思い出す。
高さ出過ぎてもなんかヤダから、
一回切りましょうこれ。
この部分だけちょっと邪魔なんで切り落としてみましょう。
あ、行けそう行けそう。行けるぞこれ。
あぁ怖い飛んでこないで…。
I☆TA☆WA!
あら、無くなっちゃった!無くなっちゃった。
すみません!無くなりました!
飛ばないように次はこん中でやります。
いっ…!あぁ～///
はいというわけで無事綺麗に取れました。
想像以上に綺麗に取れましたな。
はいこういう感じで真っ二つになりました。
でこっちが実際に使う方ですね。
あ゛痛あ゛!
もうこれだからﾎｱﾛｫｺﾄ画鋲は嫌いなんすよ～…。
これだな。これくっつきやすそうなんでこれにつけていきましょう。
あぁきたきたきた。全ベイブレードの未来がここに懸かっている。
OKOKOK。此処にくっつけます。
わぁなんか如何にもくっつきそうな感じがするんですけど。
ちゃんとね、平行にくっつけたいの。
あ、結構真っ直ぐじゃないかな。
これで暫く待ちましょう。
はいというわけで無事くっつきましたこちら!
うん、デカいな…。
恐らく最強のドライバー
「ガビョー」です。
取りあえずこの「ガビョー」を使って何かベイブレードを作ってみましょう。
これでどうでしょうか。こちら!
「ネプチューン・セントラル・ガビョー」です。
バランスのいい見た目に最強の持久力。
「ネプチューン・セントラル・ガビョー」
どんな勝負を見せるのでしょうか!
うわっ、怖…。これ大丈夫かな…。
⚠これ危ないんで真似しないでください。⚠
バーストして画鋲飛んで来たら…。
自分もバーストしますから…。
ホント目とか入ったら…ちょ俺ちょっとメット被ろう。
ホント真似しちゃダメですからね。これ目に入ったらホントに死っ…やばいですからね…。
では早速回していこうと思います。
ホント俺の目だけには入んないで…!
行きます。3,2,1,GO Shoot!
あっ、あっ、あっ、あっ…お゛お゛お゛あ゛あ゛!!
わ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛!あ゛あ゛あ゛っ!あ゛あ゛あ゛っ!!!あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛!!!
あ゛あ゛っ!凄い凄い!!
なっ何!?この動き!!
なんか凄い凄い!
ｳｱｯﾊwwwちょっと待ってwww
怪しい怪しいwww
え゛え゛え゛え゛え゛!?
わぁ～…
大丈夫か?
ちょっと不安になるｳｺﾞｯ動きだったな…。
動きが怪しかったな…。
GO Shoot!
あーでも凄い。安定力は凄いですね…。
あーあぁあぁあぁあぁああぁ…。
長いのかなぁ…。なんか違うんだよなぁ…。
なんかパッと見凄い強そうなんですけど。
なんか高すぎるんだよねやっぱり…。
これ弱点としては高さが高すぎるところですね。
ハサミで切ろう。
高さがありすぎるんでハサミで切ります。
あっ…///
OK、高さがあれなんで極限まで削ります。
あれ何処行った?
良いんじゃない?どうだ、完璧だ…。
さっきよりかなり中心を捉えたように作りました。
これはかなりいい線行くと思います。
3,2,1,GO Shoot!
ああちゃんとぽいよ!ぽい回転してるよ!
え、でも凄くない!?めっちゃ安定してる。
めっちゃ安定してる!
中心を捉えてるくらいの動きだと思います。
一応成功だと思います!
今一番強いとされている一角の「ダークデスサイザー・ヘビー・ジャイロ」です。
めっちゃ強いんすよ。
い゛や゛あ゛！
おぉー。
こいつが今一番強いって言われてそうなので、ちょっとこいつと「ネプチューン・セントラル・ガビョー」で戦っていこうと思います。
これで!どっちが一番強いか決まる!
いざ勝負!
一応この子最強なんでちょっとハンデで。
3,2,1,GO Shoot!!
行け!「ガビョー」!!
ファイアー!
行け!
勝てるぞ!いいぞいいぞ!
いいぞ!いい勝負だ!いい勝負!
いい勝負だよ!
行けるよ!
行ける!
わ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
ﾍﾟｰ→ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟー↑ﾍﾟｰ↓
ﾍﾟ↗ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰ↗
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↗ﾍﾟｰ↓
ﾍﾟ→ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰ↗ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓
ﾍﾟ→ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↓ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰｰ↓(ﾍﾟｰｯ↑ﾍﾟｰｯ↓ﾍﾟｰｯ↓ﾍﾟｯ↓)
ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟﾝ☆